j'ai vraiment rien dans le crâne
franchement je mérite pas ses pouvoirs
qu'est ce que j'apporte de plus
déjà un super héros en costume rouge
avec un éclair sur le torse y'a quoi man
qui y perd barak et supervielle batman
qui trop cool et moi je suis que moi
[Musique]
j'ai le syndrome de l'imposteur enfin
bref à sorcier m'a doté de super
pouvoirs
sauf que tous les autres en ont
maintenant on peut savoir où vous avez
on va battre ribordy
away
et il s'arrête pas la jouer perso et je
suis le seul à essayer de mettre un peu
de cohésion
je me permets de vous rappeler que je
suis pédiatre vous voyez
comment
- mehdi le sort du monde est en jeu
les filles de classement s'attaque à toi
[Musique]
des enfants qui s'empare du pouvoir de
tous les cadeaux j'en fais une affaire
personnelle
[Musique]
ok j'ai moins d'expérience que vous vu
que vous êtes super bien j'ai pas raté
un seul fast and furious ma petite dame
est donc le plus important c'est
famille les gars c'était le signal
[Musique]
le monde court à sa perte
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre ces
pouvoirs
si vous croyez qui peut quelque chose
vous vous mettez le doigt dans l'oeil
pays chacun peut être méritant
si ça change
alors va te battre pour ta famille va te
battre pour le monde
j'ai lancé suivait sur un dragon j'adore
ma life
[Musique]